I think the biggest opportunity is the
mobile connection today five billion
people out of seven million people in
the world have cell phone and that's a
fantastic opportunity because that
little gizmo in the pocket not just a
device to communicate it is a computer
and depending on the capacity of that
whether it's a smart phone or a regular
cell phone you can do whole lot of
things that was impossible to do before
just give you an example you can learn
English there's a course offered that
every day you can learn five words of
English by just turning in your cell
phone you can if you have a smartphone
you can actually download BBC apps to
learn English maybe see grammar book on
your app if you have simple basic cell
phone that can do calculation that can
send text message you can actually be in
the employment market in Kenya you can
actually register and they actually send
your text message saying you have a job
at this place and this time you can go
and get the job you have in Bangladesh
there is a thing called cell Bazaar
which is a kind of eBay on the phone you
can order things you can see what's
available and you want to sell something
you can do all that on the cell phone so
the cell phone has opened up a
tremendous opportunity that was not
existent just five ten years ago so for
me that is the most important and
promising development